what's happening everybody welcome back
to my youtube channel richard on data
and if this is your first time here my
name is richard and this is the channel
where we talk about all things data
data science statistics and programming
so subscribe for all kinds of content
just like this if you haven't already
and hit the notification bell so youtube
notifies you whenever i upload a video
so we're going to do another r tutorial
today and it's going to be over the tidy
r package
so in one of my earlier tutorials i
covered the deploy our package
and that's basically your go-to for a
lot of things data manipulation
and data wrangling related and just
generally getting your data set
into a nice clean format so that you can
go and do other things well
deployer doesn't give you every
functionality in the world
and in fact tidyr is going to be
particularly useful
when we want to convert a data frame
into what's known as a tidy format
and for those of you unfamiliar with
that term i'm going to cover it in just
a moment here
now compared to packages like dplyar or
ggplot2
i think there's comparatively fewer
functions in tidyr
that most people are going to need to be
acquainted with so we're going to step
through
six key functions from this package
today
and those are pivot longer pivot wider
separate
unite fill and complete
so just as a disclaimer the code in this
tutorial that i'm going to use
i heavily adapted from the book r for
data science by hadley wickham and
garrett grolimund
so i do highly recommend checking that
book out the link will be in the
description of this video as well as in
this script
you can get this script from my github
repo and that's also going to be in the
description of this video
now one other thing which i'm going to
link to is the cheat sheet for tidr
functions
but it's worth pointing out on this
cheat sheet
it makes use of some functions which are
at this time anyway
retired those functions are gather and
spread
now the separate and unite functions
those are still in an active development
life cycle
but gather and spread have largely been
abandoned at this point
in favor of newer functions pivot longer
and pivot wider
so just one thing to keep in mind with
the cheat sheet i have not
found a more up-to-date cheat sheet on
tidyar yet that takes this into account
now just as some usual asks before i get
into the meat of this tutorial
please smash the like button to this
video because that really does help my
content reach a larger audience
also i do have a link to my patreon
account in the description of this video
so if you guys would be willing to
support me that way that would be
enormously appreciated
so without further ado let's get into
this tutorial so the first thing that
we're going to do is call the tidy verse
package
now i mentioned this in my other
tutorials and i'll say the same thing
here
tidy verse includes tidy r but it also
includes things like dplyar and ggplot2
and tons of other incredibly useful
packages so i do highly recommend
just getting used to calling the tidy
verse directly
because it's much cleaner and more
succinct than calling a whole bunch of
individual packages separately
so before we start getting into all
these individual functions of tidy r
we have to start with an understanding
of what tidy data
actually is so tidy r
comes with it several built-in data sets
and they're called
table one two three four a four b and
five
so as one just general point when you're
writing actual code you should stay away
from
calling data frames things like table
one and table two and things like that
because that's a really easy way to
confuse and trip yourself and whoever's
looking at your code
up but nevertheless we'll work with it
here that's just the
built-in tidy r uh data frames we have
here
so if we look at table one we see a data
frame
that consists of four individual
variables those are country
year cases and population
so pretty simple and straightforward
right
now let's look at this other data frame
called table
4a now this has a lot of very similar
information
in fact it's the exact same data except
we dropped the population variable and
we just have the cases variable
except that variable year was split into
two 1999 and 2000.
so technically what's going on here is
this is really one variable year but
it's been split
into two columns 1999 and 2000
are just realizations of one single
variable
and we're gonna see a similar thing just
in the opposite direction with table two
here so it's got the same sort of
information
in it country year cases
population and then these counts so once
again
it is the exact same data that we saw in
table one
except these variables cases and
population
have been turned into rows of this data
set
so technically these observations here
are just realizations of these
individual variables
cases in population which hold all the
other variables like country and year
fixed now that you've seen some examples
of how you can represent the exact same
data in a variety of different ways
let's move on to the overall broader
concept and definition here
so actually table 1 which you saw up
above
was the only one which was tidy now the
definition of tidy data is as follows
it's that every column is a variable
then every row is an observation
and every cell is a single value
let's look back up at table 1 so that
you can see this in an example
once again every column here represents
a unique variable
every row here is an observation and
every cell here is a value
and so honestly most data sets that
you're going to run into in the real
world
are going to be untidy that doesn't mean
they're just
crappy bad data or whatever it's just
systems for generating data and
collecting it
whatever the case may be it's not
necessarily designed with the concept of
tidy data in mind
not everybody can know or design their
systems in advance
knowing that this is the most convenient
way of
storing data in r such that you can pass
your data and do
whatever the case may be visualizations
models whatever it may be
but once you have your data set in a
tidy format
it is almost invariably going to be
enormously easier to work with
so now hopefully that you understand the
concept behind tidy data
let's see how we can get untidy data
into a tidy format
so we start with table 4a let's take a
look at that up here
in our in our viewer here so this was
the instance in which we had
three columns but we had country and
then technically we have the
the variable year which is spread out
across
two different columns and then the rate
variable
is the actual value in the cells here
so what we want to actually do here is
we want to go from this wider format
where we have too many columns to a
situation where we have more rows
so we want to go from this wider data
set
to a data set that's less wide but has
more rows
and so the function that we're going to
use to do that is called
pivot longer the syntax is as follows
here
there are three key arguments here those
are
calls that is columns those are 1999
and 2000. we have this argument names
too
so we're going to condense those columns
turn it into one column
it's going to be called year and then
those values
on the inside they get their own column
and that column is called
cases and then let's just arrange by
country and year
let's see what that looks like bam it's
a tiny format
we've got country we've got year we've
got cases
again we have every column is a variable
every row is an observation and every
cell is a value so it's perfect
now one other thing that i'm going to
show you is the old gather function
because i guarantee you you're going to
see this in some code out there
and once again it is on the tidy r cheat
sheet
so it's going to do the exact same thing
here it's just the syntax is a little
bit different
so you start here by just specifying the
columns that you want to gather that's
1999 and 2000
and then instead of the argument names 2
you have an argument called
key values 2 instead of that you have
value
so the syntax is very very similar
except you just
manually specify the columns and these
argument names are different
but you can confirm just from just
looking at i ran the exact same
procedure these two different ways
and i have identical results so now that
we've covered pivot longer
let's look at the opposite problem which
is when you're going to want to use
pivot wider
so we go down here let's take a look at
uh
table two so if you remember with table
two
this was the situation in which you have
these variables cases and population
but instead of occupying their own
individual columns
they're occupying rows inside one
condensed variable called type so we
want to go from this longer data set
here
to a wider data set where cases and
population are given their own column
so that's where pivot weighter is going
to help us out
now the syntax for this is incredibly
similar to pivot longer
except instead of the arguments names 2
and values 2
we have these arguments names from and
values from
so let's just run this here uh names
from
that's coming from this variable type
and values from
are coming from count we just spread
this out
and bam we have the exact same looking
data set that we had from table one
and then similarly we have the retired
version of this function which is spread
again it's on the cheat sheet and you'll
find it in some code that's out there
it's going to do the same thing except
instead of names from
the argument is called key and instead
of values from the argument is just
called value
again we look at these two results it's
the exact same data
now we've looked at these situations
where you have rows and you want to turn
them into columns or you have columns
that you want to turn into rows
but sometimes you just have a more
simple problem where
you have a variable and you want to
split that variable into two different
variables
now this is where you're going to want
to use the separate function
let's look at table 3 and that's going
to illustrate this
so if you take a look here you'll notice
we have this variable called
rate and this is actually
just the cases and population variables
that we saw before from table one
but now they're all condensed into this
rate variable
like you have cases divided by a
population here
so you don't want that you want to split
this this up
so that's where separate is going to
come into play here
so just to walk you through the syntax
here it's very straightforward
we're going to separate the rate
variable
into two different variables
cases and population now by default
separate is going to look for the first
non-alphanumeric character and it's
going to use that as a separator
i like manually specifying this so i
just specify
sep equals the slash mark then
separate also takes this convert
argument and that's going to tell the
separate function uh
and r in general i mean look for the
closest
variable type once you split this up
because by default
this rate variable here is a character
but let's just run it here because we
specified convert equals true
our smartly figured out cases and
population are integers not characters
so just one last step for you and now
sometimes the exact opposite happens
so you have two different variables and
you want to condense them into one
single variable
so once again the exact opposite problem
that we were addressing with separate
we're going to address with the unite
function so now let's turn to table
5 here and notice that you've got
century
and year separated into different
columns here
so we want to unite these different
columns into one
single column so that's where unite is
going to come into play
and so the syntax here once again it's
pretty simple
you're going to start by specifying what
you want the new variable to be called
we're just going to call it new here and
then the columns that you want to unite
into this one single column that's
century and year
run this and see what we get so
that's a start i mean we dropped century
and year and we turn them into this
variable called
new but this isn't perfect because
it's separated by this underscore here
so once again
sometimes you have to pay a little bit
of attention to the to the default
settings for these arguments
and so let's specify a few more
arguments to unite
so once again just like before we start
with the new
variable name that's new the columns
which we want to unite into one
those are century and year what we want
the separator to be
in this case here it's just nothing it's
just the blank space
so we do that with quote mark quote mark
and then let's specify
remove equals false here uh
just because we don't necessarily want
to get rid of century and year here
i mean it'll happen uh sometimes in this
kind of situation you want to retain
these variables just for
making visualizations of just time plots
or certain models so let's not remove
them here
uh and also let's pipe to this uh turn
new into an integer uh unite
unfortunately doesn't have that
convenient
uh convert argument built into it we run
this
and this looks just like we wanted it to
we have this new column called
new it's an integer we re united century
and year
but if we want those columns for
anything they're still here
one last problem that tidy r is really
going to help you address
is instances of missing data so to get
an idea of this
let's look at an example and actually
how there's really two
very distinct types of missing data so
i just created this stocks table here
now if you notice here there's one
explicitly
missing value and that's the value for
this variable yield
when year is equal to 2015 and the
quarter is equal to four
but there's actually one separate kind
of missing value here
and it's the yield for quarter one of
2016.
so you and i can look at this data set
and we see that there's no
value for year 2016 and quarter one
although intuitively you would expect it
to be but it's not
specified in this data frame so this
type of missing value is what we would
call
implicitly missing because it's not
specified
inside of this data frame we really
should have another row here
where we've got year 2016 quarter one
and then the yield is an n a our
function for attacking the problem of
explicitly missing values
is the function fill so let's go down
here and take a look
so if we run the fill function on stocks
we're going to fill in this yield
variable
and we're going to specify this argument
dot direction to be up and yes the
argument is
dot direction you do need to specify
that dot
that's going to tell r look down and
then
fill upward so if you just compare these
two bottom to top
all we did was we took the quarter two
value for 2016
and filled it upward to quarter four of
2015
so we filled up i know it's a little
counter-intuitive
so that's going to help us tackle the
explicitly missing
uh situation now as for the implicitly
missing
uh problem our function for that is
going to be complete
now what you're going to do is you're
going to specify
the two variables for which there should
be a value
missing or otherwise for every unique
value of them
and if we look at what happened here
it's sort of like a
seed table type of situation where for
every unique
combination of year and quarter now
we have some value of yield even if that
value is missing
so this is a lot more i mean the name of
the function
says it right there it's more complete
so now hopefully you have a pretty solid
foundation in the tidy r package
and you see some instances in which it
can help you get some nice
tidy clean data and make your life
easier so
i guess have fun cleaning data so thanks
to all of you for watching this video
if you found it helpful please consider
sharing it once again
smash the like button and then i'll see
you all in the not so distant future
until then richard on data